certains athlètes sont nés ennemis mais
la rivalité la plus féroce était entre deux
combattants rasoir et enfant ils ne se sont battus que
deux fois mais le match de rancune décisif
n'a jamais eu lieu aujourd'hui j'annonce ma
retraite des boîtes professionnelles j'ai
une entreprise qui veut le
match revanche officiel ils vont  te payer cent
mille dollars je ne peux pas être dans la même pièce que
ce gars qui ne vaut pas la peine tu veux dire
qu'ils en valent la peine je regarde ta maison
oh bon secoue oublie ça sur le dinosaure
ils iront bien une dernière fois je  Je vais
essayer Mikey tu ne peux pas être mon entraîneur
peut-être que je crois que tu as mangé mon entraîneur le temps
de t'entraîner qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ouais
donne-moi une raison revient garder ces
genoux faibles tu es gros ne sois pas
honnête si  l'un de vous est assommé est-
il sûr de dire que vous êtes tombé et que vous
ne pouvez pas vous lever et que vous me rendez fou les
garçons Jésus a perdu je suis curieux de savoir s'il était cool
mec allez-vous être fougueux quand vous atteindrez la
puberté allez alors  dernière chance,
finissons-en une fois pour toutes le vieux
monde  rires répondre je fait mort je me sens
plus comme rien que je n'ai jamais ressenti ouais nous
peu importe comment vous allez les gars ce ne sera pas
votre meilleur c'est le meilleur orateur
mouvement courageux allez sans soutien-gorge j'ai fait une
décharge sur votre porche elle chat vivant nous '  Je
vis en ce moment,
hé, qu'est-ce que tu fais, nous sommes juste là
pour acheter un petit dîner, tu n'as pas à
tout frapper